90 هو تغيير اللعبة 90
الآن أنت تأمل أن يكون لديك أداة
في حربك ضد هذا الوباء والتي
يمكن أن تكون فعالة بشكل كبير
آه كم من الوقت
ستستمر هذه الحماية هو شيء
لا
نعرفه الآن ولكنه جزء
من أهداف  في الدراسة
سنتابع 44000
شخص تلقوها وهم جزء
من هذه
الدراسة لمدة عامين وخلال هذه
المتابعة من الواضح
أننا سننظر أيضًا في
متانة الاستجابات المناعية أعتقد أنه من
المحتمل أه بناءً على التأثير الذي سيكون
أعظم تقدم طبي في
المائة عام الماضية إذا فكرت في الأمر بشكل صحيح
ومن غير العادي أن يأتي
في الوقت الذي
يحتاجه العالم أكثر من غيره الآن فقط في
الولايات المتحدة لدينا 100000
ضحية شهوة كل يوم
ألف  الوفيات
كل يوم لا أستطيع إحصاء عدد الأشخاص
الذين يفقدون وظائفهم كل يوم ، لذلك
من المهم جدًا للبشرية أننا
نعتقد أننا في وضع جيد للحصول على
ما يصل إلى 50 مليون جرعة هذا العام.
y وأعتقد أننا في وضع جيد جدًا
لامتلاك 1.3 مليار جرعة
على مستوى العالم